Hey youtubers it's Charlie and because Korra
is back today I wanted to talk about the Top
5 Book 3 Characters I'm most excited about.
Almost everybody is back from Book 2, sans
Dark Avatar, but there will be several new
ones too.
Just as a heads up, because I'm at VidCon
right now it might take me a little bit longer
to get my reviews up tonight. The first episode
starts at 7PM Eastern Time on Nickelodeon.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything. I'm
doing a special giveaway. I'll explain at
the end of this video.
I don't want to spoil any big character reveals,
so these favorites only include people that
have appeared in the trailer. Just in case,
careful for mild Book 3 spoilers on character
names. Everybody ready, here we go. Number
5 - Airbending Bumi
If you've seen the other Korra videos I've
been doing lately you know I'm attributing
all the new Airbenders to Harmonic Convergence,
it's a timey wimey explanation. But the idea
is that it changed the spiritual alignment
of the physical world.
Before, the physical realm was very much cut
off from the spirit world and now that isn't
an issue anymore, so benders are popping up
everywhere. And I just love the idea of Tenzin
having to teach Bumi to master Airbending.
It's going to be really funny, but I think
it's going to bring the children of Aang together
in a way they weren't before.
During book 2 you could see that there were
a lot of old resentments that they had never
dealt with until the crisis with the dark
spirits and the Dark Avatar. Now that Bumi
is a bender, he won't feel like such an outsider
in his own family.
And Tenzin will have the satisfaction of honoring
their father's legacy by teaching his older
brother about the family business.
I know it sounds really melodramatic and cat's
in the cradle. But mostly I think it will
be a lot of funny moments like Vacation Tenzin
in book 2.
Think of the Children of Aang as like the
three stooges. I don't know which ones are
Larry, Moe or Curly.
That doesn't really address Kya in the Book
3 trailer kicking ass, but I'll talk more
about her in my review of the first couple
of episodes tonight. Because Bumi won't be
the only child of Aang going through significant
changes.
Number 4 - Lin Beifong both Young and Old
We saw a bunch of young Lin flashbacks in
the trailers and Mike and Bryan have said
for a long time that Book 3 would feature
her a lot. In present day she's going to be
dealing with her family history and her early
life in Republic City working for her mother's
police force. Yay for more Toph flashbacks.
I don't quite know how her family story will
weave into the main story about the evil bending
team, but for the first couple of episodes
they'll probably just be treated as separate
plot lines.
That metal city in the trailers is the home
of the Metal Bending Clan. We'll learn all
about them on Friday. Because Toph and the
idea of Metalbending are so connected in the
Avatar Universe, I'm totally not surprised
that a metal bending city would be part of
Lin Beifong's past.
We haven't really seen a lot of her character
in Book 1 and 2. For the most part she has
only been a part of the Republic City parts
of the story. I know a lot of you guys who
were watching my Book 2 videos weren't a huge
fan of what was done with her character last
year.
I did feel like she was a bigger part of the
story in Book 1, but I think a lot of the
reason she wasn't around in Book 2 was because
the story was mostly Water Tribe based. Now
that they're traveling to the Earth Kingdom
it's only natural that Lin would become a
much bigger part of the story.
I remember the first time I saw Korra Book
1, one of my favorite things was the Metal
Bending Police force going all spider man
with the cables all over the city. It was
the perfect example of how bending had become
more sophisticated in the 70 years since Avatar
Last Airbender.
To be fair, Meelo fart bending was a funnier
example.
There was this scene of Lin Beifong in the
trailer though that got me so pumped up. It
was of her inside a Metalbending Academy.
There wasn't a lot of context, but the scene
is part of those leaked episodes, so if you
want to talk about it please use spoiler tags.
I know everyone wants to know about the new
Airbending sub-form, but right now metalbending
is still my favorite. Blood Bending is kind
of cool, but something about metalbending
reminds me of fullmetal alchemist.
I'm actually hoping we get to see some Beifong
metal weapon crafting. I always thought Lin
putting on her metal armor in Books 1 and
2 was a subtle Iron Man reference.
Number 3 - Su Jin, Lin Beifong's Half Sister
Based on the information we have right now
I think Su Jin will be the most important
person in Lin's story during Book 3. I know
all of you guys want to know where Toph is,
but as of right now she is alive, but whereabouts
unknown. Making Su Jin the most important
member in Lin's family by default.
That doesn't mean Toph won't appear in Book
3 or Book 4, it just means she's a non-entity
for the time being. Like a ghost that haunts
Lin. Not ghost in the sense of spirits, like
Uncle Iroh last year.
Su Jin is part of the Metal Bending clan storyline,
so we might not meet her until the second
or third episode, but expect some heavy drama
during their early family scenes.
Usually when someone like Lin never chooses
to talk about her past or her family, it's
because something bad happened. Speaking of
which, we are going to find out how Lin got
that scar on her face.
If you loved all the Aang Republic City flashbacks
in book 1, you're going to love the Lin/Toph
flashbacks in Book 3. I'm not expecting to
see any flashbacks until after the second
episode. Book 3 is supposed to pick up a couple
of months after the end of Book 2. So they'll
still be dealing with the aftermath of the
Dark Avatar.
Number 2 - Old Man Zuko
If you didn't read The Search or The Promise
comics, you really haven't seen Zuko since
Last Airbender went off the air. It was said
in those stories that sometime after becoming
Firelord Zuko and starting a family, he passed
the title of Firelord to his daughter and
started traveling the world as an ambassador
for peace.
Based on the trailers it seems like recently
he's been working with the Order of the White
Lotus. Or maybe he's been working with them
this whole time.
It seems like slowly as week get closer and
closer to Book 4 the surviving members of
the Original Team Avatar start manifesting
themselves. That makes me curious if Toph
won't appear till Book 4.
There's so many unanswered Zuko questions
I want answered in Book 3 though. Who was
his wife, will we meet his daughter, General
Iroh's mother. We met him in Book 2, in case
you missed it, he was voiced by Dante Basco.
He's not doing the voice for Old Zuko, usually
when they bring Last Airbender voice actors
back they have them voice new characters.
That's why Grey Delisle is voicing the evil
waterbender. Currently Azula's whereabouts
are unknown, even though sparky sparky boom
girl resembles her a lot.
It seems like a lot of Zuko's story will take
place separately from Korra's, at least at
the start of Book 3. But I'm hoping we get
to see him teach her some special Firebending
techniques.
Remember during Book 2 Beginnings, we saw
Avatar Wan learn the Dragon Dance from the
Dragon spirit, then we saw Zuko and Aang learn
it during Last Airbender?
Wouldn't it be cool if he taught it to Korra
at some point. It's true she could have known
it already because Aang learned it and she
possessed all his memories. But since those
are gone she won't have that Avatar Hard Drive
to access anymore.
and the number 1 character I'm looking forward
to is a four way tie for what I'm calling
the evil bending team. If this were The Karate
Kid movie, they would be Cobra Kai. "No mercy
in our Dojo"
I'm hoping that first or second episode introduces
them all. I don't want to talk about them
too much, but here are their names:
The Firebender, Sparky Sparky Boom girl is
Pey Li
The Water Bender is Ming Jua
The Airbender is Zaheer
and we don't know the name of the Earthbender
yet.
They have a weird history with Korra when
she was a baby that Zuko will explain. There's
rumors that part of Book 3 will involve a
plot about controlling future Avatars. If
you can predict which Bending tribe the next
avatar will come from, you can influence the
next Avatar if you're sneaky enough.
It's unclear how the evil bending team is
tied up in all this, but there's going to
be so many classic avatar last airbender callbacks,
if you were a fan of that series. You're going
to love Book 3.
Now it's your turn, let me know which character
you're most excited about in Book 3.
I didn't mention him, but Bolin would be my
bonus choice, fingers crossed Bolin learns
to metalbend this year.
Here's the details on my Book 3 review videos
tonight. Because they're airing the first
three episodes back to back, what I'm doing
is posting a review of the first two episodes
combined right after the episode airs. Be
sure to subscribe to get it.
Then Saturday I'll post a review of that third
episode. And because that's three Korra videos
in two days I'm not doing a Q&A video this
week. But I will be giving away three separate
gift cards for each of those three episodes.
Two in that first review video tonight and
one for the saturday video.
All you have to do to participate is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on one of those
videos.
I should be able to post my review tonight
by 9PM Eastern Time. But if you're worried
about missing it, just follow me on twitter
or facebook. I'm pretty good about posting
updates there. Links for all that at the bottom
of the description.
Right now click here for my Episode 1 and
2 review video, I'll add the annotation as
soon as I post it. and click here for my giant
Korra master playlist. It has all the Korra
videos I've done.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight,
High Fives!